in the middle of summer when infections
of kova 19 are usually low a new variant
ba-5 is sweeping across america the
number of new infections is skyrocketing
but experts say cases are severely
underreported as more people use at-home
tests or don't test at all there's a
hundred thousand over a hundred thousand
cases on average being reported on a
daily basis we're probably detecting one
in ten infections right now so it's
probably more like a million the latest
surge is hitting americans from new
england to california officials in
massachusetts are urging people to wear
masks again in indoor public settings
cases of covet 19 have shot up nearly 40
percent in boston in a week in san diego
an indoor mass mandate for summer school
takes effect monday doctors warn there
is little protection against this new
strain this is a version of the virus
that can escape any of the immunity you
had from an infection previously as well
as from a vaccine it poses a risk for a
majority of the population
health experts say vaccines still
protect against severe disease
hospitalization and death but there are
concerns about what repeated covet
infections are doing to patients each
time you get reinfected that's another
chance for the virus to cause lots of
different problems while federal health
officials deal with this latest coven 19
wave cases of monkey pox are
dramatically surging too patients
desperate for vaccines are waiting in
long lines from san francisco to new
york as demand for the shots far
outstrip supply
we need more vaccines
quickly the centers for disease control
is prioritizing vaccine distribution in
hard-hit cities like new york the
epicenter of the virus three vaccination
centers opened there on sunday but only
for one day due to the limited supply
there's a total of approximately 4 200
appointments just for today outbreaks of
monkey pox are being reported in at
least 43 states while covert 19 is
surging in at least 39 states a double
challenge for federal health officials
racing to distribute more monkey pox
vaccines while urging americans to get
another covet 19 booster shot
jennifer johnson global news washington